- [Voiceover] The first
thing I googled was
how to teach a guy without
arms to shoot a bow.
And there's nothing out there like that.
Because it's such a rare thing.
(intense violin music)
(bow shooting and striking)
My name is Matt Stutzman,
I'm from Fairfield, Iowa.
And I'm a professional archerer.
- Well, that's how I shoot, there you go.
In 1982, I was born as you see me
right now, without any arms.
I never see not having
arms as a limitation.
It's amazing how your body,
when it's missing something,
your other limbs take off and
kind of pick up the slack.
So for me, my feet are my hands.
Everything that I have in
my life, I do with my toes.
It's pretty rare that I don't
use my feet for something.
My phone, for example,
how I pick up my phone,
I'd actually grab it
with my foot and flip it
and catch it and be like hello.
When I got started shooting,
it took me about two weeks
from looking at a bow till
shooting probably my first arrow.
Because I had to figure out how to hold it
with this toe or this toe
or this foot or that foot.
I had to kinda think
outside the box and come up
with some creative ways of shooting.
I actually hold the bow with my right foot
but I will pretend it's
somebody's right arm in my mind.
And then I have a release
aid that goes over my right
shoulder and I actually
hook that onto the string.
And when I sit up, I push
my foot away from my chest
which draws the bow, at
this point, I'm aiming.
I don't see a guy without arms shooting.
I see somebody with arms shooting
and I guess it's just how I imagine it.
(bow releasing and striking)
So I did repetitions, I sat in a chair
for eight hours a day, six days a week.
Time, kind of, slows way down.
You forget who's around you, you forget
what you're doing almost
and you're so focused
on one thing, shot and shot
and shot and shot and shot.
That’s all I did, this
bow right here probably
has a million arrows shot through it.
At the end of the day, ya
know, it helps you become good.
A couple medals or trophies
that stand out to me
is my paralymics silver
medal, I also have the
Guinness world record for the
longest accurate archery shot.
And I shot an arrow and hit
a target from 310 yards away.
I want my kids to see that no matter what
the challenge is you can overcome it.
You just have to put your
head down and push through
and figure out a way to be successful.
Figure out a way to just, ya know,
be a good person while
you do all that stuff.
At the end of the day I just want to be
the best in the world, I
don't care if you have arms,
you don't have arms, I
don't care if you were
the Michael Jordan of the sport
and you're an able-bodied archer.
I just want to beat you 'cause I
want to be known as the
best archer in the world.
(arrow releasing and striking)
(upbeat techno music)